and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review the saga like yeah I
want to suck your spoilers there's this
boy who's a vampire and this this girl
who also wants to be a vampire
so the vampire is like I have to go away
you never see you again because I love
you too much most men are I'm gonna go
away never seen you again and sleep with
a bunch of different women why because I
love you I tried saying that to a woman
once she cut my balls off so the vampire
goes away because you know he loves her
too much but that is long hair guy comes
along with big sharp teeth and huge
muscles and he's and he's like no I am
not to wear well because your werewolf
you serious man no I'm an everyday
ordinary kid just like that damn kid who
wears all black and he's totally not a
vampire okay so he's like don't worry
pretentious girl I'll look after you but
the girl is like told me to piss off and
never see him again I think he loves me
but I join all the werewolf boy is
attacked by the same curse that every
other boy in this movie is attacked with
and that's the curtains of missing
shirts I mean it no boy in this movie
has this shirt I wear this bar to high
school all they have to do speak to
their teeth and yell every word tonight
when dying and I gotta haul to werewolf
boy he's totally trying to put the hits
on the girl and he's like please let me
go out with you I am compassionate
caring strong dependable and I'm 83 time
that you know character girl is like no
I want the vampire why because he stared
at me you need to ensure that the girl
can see the vampire whenever she gets an
adrenaline rush so this encourages her
to do all sorts of crazy things
jump up could crash a motorcycle sign on
to do another Twilight movie but
don't do these crazy things or I will
stare at you some more foreign country
fire is like I'm going to expose myself
to the world by making myself sparkle
like a girl toy he said nobody is
already fuckin comes and pushes them out
of the Sun so I'm like already happy but
we need filler for the next movie boom
so the League of super duper vampires
want to talk to the vampire boy in the
girl and one of the leaders is to come
enough Fanning I always knew she was a
vampire projected like you thirty years
old when she was only five so they're
all like we seen into the future know
that this girl is going to turn into a
vampire but the boy vampire is like she
can't join us she's not pretentious
enough he is cool
so the werewolf boy sees the vampire and
the girl are together and he's like the
vampires the world will start war so you
have to choose girl whose side you're
going to be on but why did you lie to
you every kind gentle person who would
never let you down and protect you
forever
it's good point how about you he made
seriously what is wrong with you
villainy teenage girl a little bit voice
treat me like crap dude you could have
you never understand so the girl was the
vampire to turn her into a vampire but
he's like on one condition
and what's that marry me to be
protective he continued crazy so this
movie was really great even though I was
wishing the werewolf or rip the vampires
head off but maybe it's why I love the
movie so much it always leaves you
wanting more mark common sense more
logical reasoning don't worry players
that shine make sparkling toothpaste I
bet their blood is minty this is just
her a bone saying
come on J come on I can with his
tormented SI vampire caddy just force me
to read the books
Oh